Welcome, everybody.
We're going to sort of close out
the Cancun cruise fiasco a little bit later in the
show, but to talk about sort of good things that
came out of this horrible situation in Texas, we
have a remarkable situation in the United States
where a Democratic New York congresswoman.
Seems to be better representing the interests
of Texas residents than their own actual
Republican U.S. Senator Ted Cruz, I'm talking
about Democratic Congresswoman Alexandria Castillo
Cortez, as well as Texas Democrat Betty O'Rourke
and other Democrats who came together. And while
Ted Cruz was flying back and forth to Cancun,
Mexico, appearing on the Sean Hannity program to
give conflict conflicting and bizarre explanations
about exactly why he thought it was a good idea
at any point to go to Cancun in the midst of
storms and power outages afflicting his state. In
the midst of all that, Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
took to Twitter to announce a fundraising effort.
Within two hours, she raised three hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars. By yesterday
morning, she and Beto O'Rourke and others
had raised more than four million dollars. And
there's a good chance that by the time you listen
to today's show and watch this clip, she will
have raised five million or more dollars for
Texas victims of these storms and power outages.
She also didn't just do online fundraising.
She actually went down to fill up food boxes at
a Houston food bank with representatives Sylvia
Garcia and Al Green and Sheila Jackson Lee. And
in the midst of all of this insanity with Texas
politicians who voted against Hurricane Sandy
aid. But that said, give us the Texas aid now
for the power outages and flew to Cancun and back
and said, oh, the girls wanted to go on a trip.
It is Alexandria Castillo Cortez, supposedly
enemy number one for a lot of these Republicans
who has actually put boots on the ground
for lack of a better term, raised money,
got food boxes together for people unable to
get food. And again, when you are a Texas voter
and you see that a Democratic congresswoman from
another state is doing more for you than your own
senator, it really should make you reconsider
whether you are represented by the best people.
And I sent out a couple of tweets about this.
I tweeted over the weekend, Have Ted Cruz,
Greg Abbott and others thanked AOC for her
huge fundraising for Texas victims of the
storms and power outages. As of this moment,
they have not. But I wouldn't be surprised
if at some point they sort of feel obligated
to put together some kind of perfunctory
thank you to all of those who have helped us in
our relief efforts. Also, I tweeted this morning,
the Texas fundraising story is crazy. It
genuinely seems like AOC and Beto O'Rourke
haven't embezzled any of the money nor put
their families on staff to funnel cash to them,
something that became basically standard operating
procedure under the Trump administration. Donald
Trump putting everybody from Larra Trump to who
knows who else on his campaign staff, paying them
one hundred and eighty grand a year and so on and
so forth. Now, what just one other side story with
the insanity of this not only have and better work
done more for Texas than has Ted Cruz, Ted Cruz
ended up desperately attempting a PR photo op
where he was putting packages of bottled water
in the trunks and vehicles of Texans. And
it's like there's no more pathetic attempt
to make up for his flying to Cancun than to be
photographed handing out water. But that raised
another question. Why isn't Ted Cruz in quarantine
right now? Ted Cruz flew to Mexico and then flew
back the next day. Was he tested in Mexico in
the 20 hours or 18 hours that he was there? Do
we know for sure that Ted Cruz is not potentially
positive for coronavirus right now? Shouldn't he
be a.. And absent a coronavirus test quarantining
right now rather than out and about like?
We may never know the answers to these questions.
And of course, we were all asking. Wait a second.
He he had Ted Cruz admits that he had a bunch
of his daughter's friends over for dinner the
day before going to Cancun, and then he went
to Cancun and then he flew back the next day.
Is he being tested at any point during this? Is he
adhering to the protocols about requiring tests to
go to Mexico, to come back to Mexico by the United
States? We just have no idea. And we may never
even get answers to these questions, but they're
questions we're not ignoring. Is it some kind
of exception for senators? I don't know. But we
should be getting answers to this. And, of course,
with Ted Cruz, as with many of these people, it's
yeah, sure, these are the rules, but not for me.
And that seems to apply, unfortunately, to many
of our leaders. And it's not just Republicans that
that's the case with. But we will talk a little
bit more about the Ted Cruz fiasco later on.